political agreement
to a new package of sanctions against
russia
i welcome this
russia's decision to recognize the
ukrainian regions of donetsk and luhansk
is illegal and completely unacceptable
the same is true for the decisions to
send troops to these regions we cannot
accept this
this decision violates the territorial
integrity and the sovereignty of ukraine
russia is not respecting its
international obligations
and it is violating core principle of
international law
russia has manufactured this crisis and
is responsible for the current
escalation
we will now quickly finalize the
sanctions package and we will coordinate
closely with our partners
as we have done so far
this solid package contains a number of
calibrated measures
it is a clear response
to these violations of international law
by the kremlin
the sanctions directly target
individuals and companies
involved in these actions
they target banks
that finance the russian military
apparatus and cons constitute and
contribute to the destabilization
of ukraine
and we are also banning trade between
the two breakaway regions and the
european union as we've done after the
illegal annexation of crimea in 2014
and finally
we're limiting the russian government's
ability to raise capital on the eu's
financial markets
we will make it as difficult as possible
for the kremlin to pursue its aggressive
actions
on north stream 2
i think the german government is
absolutely right
no stream 2 has to be assessed
in light of the security of energy
supply for the whole european union
because this crisis shows that europe is
still too dependent on russian gas
we have to diversify our supplies
and we have to go to reliable suppliers
we will have to massively invest in
renewable energy that's where the future
is because this is a strategic
investment in our energy independence
our action today is a response to
russia's aggressive behavior
if russia continues to escalate this
crisis that it has created
we are ready to take further action in
response
the european union is united and acting
fast
[Applause]